hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes it's a nice
Sunday so I thought why not give it a go
and yesterday we lost a game to a to a
fairly higher rated opponent he was some
2 400 something and he outplayed us but
we did have chances in that game only we
did not take advantage of them so this
one I will again try to play good moves
I will try to play them faster than in
the previous games uh so let's see how
it goes let's uh create a game here 10
minutes per player and uh let's uh see
if we can do better in this one uh
hopefully you you will get some use out
of this and it will help you improve
your own games uh I still didn't I hope
I don't get the black piece because I
still didn't do a a proper course on the
trpovski he really surprised me with a
trpovski in the previous game uh so
hopefully we don't we don't get that uh
but yeah let's see who our opponent is
for this one uh let's turn off Zen mode
it is M MX Z from Antarctica uh doubtful
but you never know uh and he goes for
the immediate the G6 all right we're
going to play it uh fairly standard the
D4 uh we're going to grab the full
Center and uh we're going to see what
kind of a setup is he going for we're
going to go for F4 right away uh just to
make it a little bit interesting all
right so he goes for uh he goes for uh
attacking my center and we're going to
defend it with uh with what let's
Advance the pawn okay let's see let's
see what he had in mind uh I will fully
allow him to develop uh whatever he
wants all right so he captures we're
going to capture with the queen then if
he goes Knight C6 we're going to pin the
pin the Knight so H we also get some
developing moves in and uh yeah okay a
nice check we can simply block and
defend our Bishop we don't have to worry
about that uh but he does have his dark
Square bishop and this diagonal has been
opened up so once we Castle we're also
going to have to play King H1 fairly
fairly quickly you never know for the
moment the bishop is in G7 but that uh
that can change easily
and I do like my queen okay so he goes
here he wants to attack my queen further
which I don't mind okay it's a it's a
nice uh nice idea uh so do we go for do
we go for Knight C3 to pressure the pawn
he goes
E6 do we go for
that what is a good way to to handle
things
here yeah we're going to go Knight the C
three we're going to okay this is this
is fine I don't mind that uh he's going
to have to play E6 just so he doesn't
get the bishop into the game uh so later
on he will have to figure out how to get
the bishop into the game and while
Knight to F5 is very nice uh we can
always kick it away with with the G4 I'm
considering maybe even a queenside
castles here yeah the Knight coming here
is nice but I don't think it's like too
nice
but how to develop the bishop that's the
real question here
H yeah I don't want to give up my Bishop
that's uh that's for
sure how to go about this play B3 but
that really weakens the Knight here so
we don't want to do
that
huhuhuh no I think kingside castles it
is for this one kingside castles it is
here yeah he's going to play Knight here
we're just going to move the knight uh
and then even if he delivers some sort
of a check we do have the the3 square
covered by our Queen and Bishop so he
can't really Force anything here okay so
he just uh goes to safety now we kind of
have to figure out do we want to trade
here uh I'm kind of not against trading
but but uh yeah I don't want to I don't
want to do it uh sort of
preemptively yeah I mean Bishop pair is
a bishop pair as long as it's in the
game it's uh it's useful to have it and
now we get out of any Knight jumps we
don't have to worry about Knight
captures uh yeah for those of you who
are new to chess whenever you're pinning
something like this in your opponent
castles don't forget that Knight
captures Queen becomes a possibility you
know it does happen even at this
level all right so next we're going to
if he goes Queen B6 yeah that's not
really an issue he he will probably just
slowly develop with Bishop D7 or A6 B5
and
B4
so
yeah it's U it's position I I think uh I
think this could be even a z00
position okay the Knight here it's a
it's a fine Square for the Knight like
it always had it always has F5 later on
since it's a closed Center I can uh kick
it away with the G4 so he's going to
wait for me to decide how to uh how to
set up everything and then he will
decide whether he's going to go to to F5
or not but uh since it's the only Square
for the Knight the Knight is coming to
F5 make no mistake
there yeah and I have to figure out how
to develop if he doesn't play it right
away then I can even go Bishop E3 and
sort of harass The Rook here with my
double uh with my Bishop pair uh so
those are some things the four yeah okay
you can play that but uh uh giving up D4
Square to my knight I don't think it's
uh I don't think it's very impressive
okay so now he's um he's offering me
this capture which might be interesting
because then I have Knight A4 to
C5 and there's really not uh not a clear
way of how to stop
that
yeah we're going to no I still don't
want to take yeah but if I push here B5
can be played and if Bishop to
B3 yeah he can be a little bit annoying
but no I'm not going to I'm not going to
capture for capture
sake but yeah I I can't uh uh I can't
forget about King to H1 I have to play
it at some point because it does make it
a bit uh difficult to to develop
yeah okay it's a it's a nice position
it's a nice position I like his position
I like my position okay we're just going
to put the bishop on
B3
um since the Knight re has no real
purpose on C3 it doesn't really do all
that
much like it does pressure the center
that's
true um now Knight F5 nah Bishop to B7
can be played although I don't see I
don't see a scenario where this Pawn
touches D4 unless unless he plays it
like right away but I don't think that's
going to happen cuz imagine this Knight
on D6 that's an absolute monster so D4
is not an option so maybe kiing get away
with B4 first yeah okay can be played
but I actually like the the Knight on
A4 um and then D4 maybe no he's going to
go for Knight to
B4 with uh with what idea what's the
idea
here I go if I go Queen D4 he's just
going to move it
back
yeah all right let's repeat once I'm
going to play Queen D4 but no he wants
to play Maybe n it's nothing yeah he'll
probably just move it back and then I'm
going to play Queen Queen D3 and if he
repeats once again uh then okay no he
just wants that okay that's
interesting yeah okay let's play A3
since A3 is very useful for
us he's going to attack the queen
again and yeah we're we're actually very
happy on
D3 we actually very happy on
D3 the bishop here yeah uh it's a nice
piece also defense C2 now he could go
after the bishop but
uh yeah maybe maybe yeah maybe Knight A5
attacks the bishop and then he lands it
on C4 so it could be that if he he
attacks it I can just leave it there uh
because capturing uh C captures no he's
going to develop first okay uh makes
sense uh and uh now we're now we're
bringing the the bishop to F4 sorry to
E3
gaining more control over the D4 Square
uh if he goes after it with Knight to F5
we can put it on F2 before kicking away
the Knight with
G4 and
uh yeah okay D4 now might be a move
because Knight captures and then Rook
here but also Knight captus attacks the
queen so it's really not yeah he wants
to put pressure on the C file okay let's
just
uh
H yeah very nice let's go Rook D1 let's
go Rook
[Music]
D1 yeah this D4 Pawn push might be an
issue at some point okay so he does go
for
this um which uh yeah it's nice it's
nice uh but we're just going to force
the
capture yeah we're just going to force
capture we're just going to force the
capture and this game we're even doing
okay on time yeah but it's only like the
the first half of the first half of the
game we're still uh messing around with
the middle game and now if he goes uh
Knight
C4 yeah it's a it's a nasty piece to to
have on C4 I might even have to capture
it
but
I might even have to capture but then
I'm going to REM maneuver my Bishop yeah
okay but he does it um goes after the B2
Pawn uh we're going to
capture which does improve his Center a
little
bit but not a
lot yeah I'm guessing B captures opening
up the center I I don't think it makes
any sense for him like Queen D7 is just
uh Queen D7 is just very
nice yeah and if we can if we can shift
the bishop to B4 and land on D6 could be
very annoying for him
uh yeah Knight F5 uh doesn't have all
that many great squares so we're just
going to kick it away like we said so
yeah we'll see what it does we'll see
what it does it's
interesting
he might also play Rook yeah he might
just also play Rook Capt no he goes with
the B Pawn Yeah makes sense so now uh
now we're going to play Queen to E3
simply to keep control over this
diagonal and also uh also free up the D4
Square for our Knight yeah if Knight
here again it's the same thing Queen F2
followed by G4 so we're not worried
about
that and we do have sufficient control
over this diagonal and we still haven't
played King to H1 I know it's a it's a
crime against chess but uh I just never
had the time he he continues the the
pressure uh yeah we also have to figure
out uh if we get sort of a a breeding
move in do we have something like Knight
A4 maybe maybe maybe really gaining
control over this C5
square or do we keep the Knight here he
goes after
okay
fine okay so he stops
G4 um yeah if I play H3 he's just going
to play
H5 so we have to do it like like tal
thought us uh play G3 first then you
play H3 and only then you execute G4
that's how the great Misha said it
should be done I I once uh saw a game he
played in the in the Bon and then he
said like don't play A6 B5 you have to
play B6 A6 and B5 otherwise your
opponent will just blockate the position
with A4 A5 and it's uh you know
something that uh you can maybe use in
every game you play like uh it's not the
exact same possession but it just you
know gives you an
idea okay so we're uh much better on
time so our opponent uh at some point
will have to do
something uh as the okay so what's
Bishop here he wants to go after my
Bishop but this also allows uh yeah so
we're just um we're just going to yeah
Rook B8 sort of does pressure to B2 Pawn
but we we have an in between Bishop C5
so we don't have to worry about
that yeah G4 is
coming yeah now Rook B8 here and then
G4
okay uh oh he wants to play this
really
okay it's
fair I don't
mind the Knight goes
back attacks the
pawn yeah that's uh that's actually not
bad that's actually not bad
I have to play this at least for the
moment yeah
D4 um at this point with 2 minutes on
the clock I would just give up the D4
Pawn to open up this
diagonal since uh without having that as
counterplay I don't see a way for him
to to actually do all that much yeah
we're going to play this just uh keep
control over the bishop
wow wow I actually blundered a full
Bishop here full
Knight
yeah yeah that's very sad
I have no idea why I thought I had
this I have no idea why I thought I had
this okay now it's uh I should just
resign
here yeah I think up until this point we
were we were perfectly fine but yeah now
that uh now that he played this and I I
I probably didn't have the Knight a for
move because I always thought yeah I
have A4 uh doesn't really matter what
happens
yeah do we still have any counterplay
here that's the that's the
question doesn't appear so yeah okay so
he goes
here yeah let's go
here still has a minute on the clock so
I'm going to try and punish him for for
taking so much time to find
moves but it's not going to be
easy
yeah I can't really can't really play
any sort of a breakthrough here yeah
okay so he goes for that uh we're going
to play Rook e one followed by Rook e
three just trying to make something out
of the
position okay so he goes back he has to
figure out a way how to actually put
pressure uh let's go
here yeah a check on the light squares
isn't all that
impressive yeah so he wants to trade as
he should yeah we're going to trade and
go Rook
here go back with the
Knight okay now once the Knight lands on
G6 now we can actually go for
some mating ideas
here yeah he does have one check it's
not much okay so he wants to trade
Queens and he successfully finds
it yeah we have to trade here do we yeah
we have to trade
unfortunately unfortunately we have to
trade yeah okay we're going to go after
the after the king
here uh just King E7 yeah it's perfectly
fine there's nothing here nothing at
all can we still make it interesting at
least
okay
he's giving up the Knight here it's very
interesting obviously we want to deliver
Checkmate which he will not
allow let's go
here let's go can we take a pawn we can
take a
pawn let's go after another
Pawn H he has eight seconds so I think
we can actually just play this and still
win
uh there we go no he finds it he finds
it tricky tricky
stuff there we go all right uh I had to
I had to punish him as he spent too much
time uh uh after you know for the game
I'm not proud of it but
uh yeah I've lost way too many games on
time
so let's uh let's see what what we did
here H it's uh okay uh you you will
blunder I will blunder everyone blunders
that's not the point point is you know
uh recollect and continue playing solid
moves or at least moves that will allow
you to win the game yeah I play D5 okay
uh yeah even D captures and C5 so yeah
those these are um the moves that uh you
always should play like I've mentioned
in my previous video like Fabi always
plays s such a move uh but uh you know I
thought it's some some line maybe I
don't know okay yeah this is perfectly
fine uh I'm just interested in the
general game game plan okay so obviously
you should capture here with some Knight
A4 yeah okay we did discuss this sort of
gaining control over the dark
squares I I prefer to keep the tension
with the Bishop pair maybe allowing him
a bit too much yeah A3 we just go back
okay Bishop
B3 yeah it's still Z zero territory and
now okay capturing the the bishop is the
way to go I thought this would be
nicely like what captures captures and
B4 okay and now I can either triple my
pawns or go here yeah and then he goes
Bishop C6 yeah that's that's the way to
do it
yeah and now Bishop B5 okay okay so
that's the the fault with the with the
tactics here but he captured
here uh yeah we we sort of had
everything under control G3 no
H3 really
H3 and never worry about G4 yeah okay I
guess the idea is that if Queen and
Knight are covering H4 that they have to
remain here for forever I went for this
which is still fine yeah nothing nothing
wrong with this I play Knight H2 yeah
and see now uh this is where I blunder
yeah here in this crucial position
Bishop D4 sort of gives me a plus
1.5 uh I blundered the Knight here and
now okay uh analyzing this is uh really
a moot point uh but I did manage to to
sort of get a tricky position and he got
scared as he was getting very long time
I threatened Checkmate here he defended
with the bishop and uh yeah
here was the where he resigned uh of
course the position is completely
winning for him but yeah to to to little
time on the clock uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it you know
everything up until the point I
blundered is sort of valuable advice
there were of course better moves as
there always are but you know the the
it's it's the thought behind the moves
that counts and if you use it in your
own games without blundering you will
achieve greatness of course
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day